merci merci et pardon à huy la rouille
l'aca changement à nouveau merci le mois
on a souhaité faire ce point presse
compte tenu de la journée de demain
d'abord pour
dire que bien entendu dans l'homme on
respecte à la fois le droit le droit de
grève c'est une évidence et le droit de
manifester en revanche je pense que la
france ne peut pas se payer le luxe d'un
deuxième blocage on a vu l'échec de la
méthode macron il ya un an on peut pas
repartir dans un blocage à répétition de
cette manière on est nous dans une
situation aujourd'hui on a une
proposition très concrète qui est qui et
sur la qui est sur la table avec un
certain nombre de d'engagement sur ce
dossier des retraites sur lesquels on a
travaillé de longues dates
c'est tout d'abord de dire que les seuls
qui ont réformé système de retraites
c'est la droite on l'a fait en 93
on l'a fait en 2003 on l'a fait en deux
en 2010 avec des vraies réformes
or aujourd'hui on a un président de la
république et un gouvernement qui sont
totalement anxiogène qui génère de
l'anxiété et de l'inquiétude partout
personne n'est capable de dire qu'elle
sera là la réforme puisque entre le
président de la république le premier
ministre les ministres
le haut-commissaire tout le monde se
contredit en permanence on ne sait pas
où on va
j'ai n'en génère de l'inquiétude est
donc on se trouve dans ce dans ce
mouvement de grève important demain
parce que effectivement cette anxiété
qui est ressenti par tous les partout
les français sur le fond nous la
première chose c'est que on souhaite
garantir le système par répartition
on y attache et ça veut dire très
concrètement que il ne peut pas dans
notre esprit y avoir une baisse des
pensions
contrairement à ce qui a été fait par le
gouvernement
avec l'augmentation de la csg il ne peut
pas y avoir d'augmentation des
cotisations comme le le gouvernement
précédent l'avait l'a fait et c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans ce système par
répartition on a fait clairement le
choix de la mesure d'âge c'est-à-dire
d'allonger la durée de cotisation avec
un report de l'âge de l'âge légal dans
la continuité de la réforme de 2010 qui
avait été faite par nicolas sarkozy et
qui était une réforme qui a été compris
par tout le monde ça a suscité une
mobilisation mais il y avait une réforme
sur la table et qui est rentré en action
on n'était pas dans une réforme qui qui
qui prendrait effet 40 ans 40 ans plus
tard la deuxième la deuxième chose qui
est qui est importante pour pour nous
c'est de préserver ce qui fonctionne il
y a des choses qui fonctionnent et qui
fonctionne bien les caisses autonomes
elles fonctionnent aujourd'hui pour un
raison simple c'est d'abord qu'elles
sont bien gérées ensuite souvent il ya
des niveaux de cotisations plus élevées
et comme il risque d'y avoir des
incidences démographique dans un certain
nombre de secteurs où on a beaucoup de
cotisants peu de pensionnés c'est ses
caisses sont excédentaires par leur
bonne gestion dont qui permettra lorsque
la démographie s'inverse d'avoir la
capacité d'y répondre
donc allez faire un hold up sur ces sur
ses quais c'est invraisemblable donc on
s'oppose à ce que l'on touche à ce qui
fonctionne bien aujourd'hui alors on va
pas tous les prendre mais tous et ses
caisses autonomes ont un bon
fonctionnement ensuite il y a le
principe de justice et d'équité avec le
fait aussi que l'on assume un calendrier
de sortie des régimes spéciaux
on va pas les arrêter du jour au
lendemain mais on s'engage sur un sur un
calendrier lors ça fait partie des
points sur lesquels on continue de
travailler pour voir comment peut se
faire le glissement mais il faut sortir
de ces régimes spéciaux avec un sujet
qui est aussi celui de la pénibilité où
on est là dans une usine à gaz disons
lot est telle que c'est aujourd'hui moi
je pense qu'il faut reposer à plat ce
problème de la pénibilité et à mon avis
le traité à l'échelle de l'antre des
entreprises ou dans les accords de
branche lorsqu'on est sur des
entreprises de plus petite taille parce
qu'on voit bien la difficulté qu'il y
aujourd'hui avec le système qui en place
ensuite dernier point c'est c'est très
lié aux principaux systèmes par
répartition et aux principes mutualistes
de sanctuariser les droits familiaux et
les droits conjugaux notre système y
tient parce que on a une politique
familiale et si ce qui a permis entre
autres d'avoir une base solide le
système par répartition il faut que la
base soit la plus large et la plus
solide possible
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir une politique
familiale et ça veut donc dire qu'on ne
peut pas remettre en cause cette
politique familiale
elle a déjà été bien ébréchée par par la
gauche
et là on voit bien que elle est
clairement dans le viseur donc ça veut
dire qu'on reste attaché à la fois aux
majorations de pensions et aux
bonifications trimestre puisque
l'argument qu'ils utilisaient de dire
mais voyez on va tout régler parce que
on le fera dès le début dès le premier
enfant mais c'est les bonifications de
trimestre mais les majorations de
pensions donc les droits familiaux les
droits conjugaux doivent bien être
maintenue voilà la ligne sur laquelle
nous sommes et on continue à avancer
dans le cadre d'un groupe de travail
interne où on a déjà eu beaucoup de
de concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux inquiet présidée par stéphane
viry avec avec eric woerth et rené paul
savary du sénat est en avance sur 7 sur
cette ligne voilà ce qu'on vous dit bien
sûr à votre disposition eric woerth a
dit qu'il était plutôt favorable à une
réforme par point d'ailleurs la réforme
de 2010 envisager cette option qu'il est
la position des républicains là dessus
non nous sommes on l'a vu avec avec eric
avec tout le monde le système par points
il existe aujourd'hui en retraite
complémentaire et c'est plutôt un bon
système
en revanche on reste attaché au système
par répartition qui doit être le socle
avec la nécessité de maintenir politique
familiale et c'est un point qui fait
l'unanimité comme tous ceux que j'ai
évoqué là on les a évoqués en commission
comité stratégique encore la semaine
dernière
bonjour thomas souliers bfm tv on
comprend vos désaccords sur la réforme
proposée par emmanuel macro mais on voit
qu'on est attaché au système par
répartition macro si on voit que vous
les supprimez même à terme les régimes
spéciaux emmanuel macron aussi est ce
que votre opposition cette réforme est
une posture politique ou vraiment sur le
fond trouvé que la copie que l'on
connaît pour l'instant est inacceptable
écoutez moi la difficulté c'est à
connaître la copie parce que je sais pas
ce qu'il en est nous la position on a le
mérite qu'elle soit clair qu'elles
soient partagées et d'avoir fait pas mal
de concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux et je viens de l'évoquer là
moi je ne sais pas aujourd'hui j'ai beau
lire et être attentifs aux déclarations
des ministres les uns après les autres
et celle du président de la république
la clause du grand père c'est pas nous
qui l' menton c'est le président de la
république qui fait cette déclaration en
disant ça concernera les nouveaux
entrants c'est intenable de dire cela il
le dit à propos de la sncf mais mais si
ça concerne les nouveaux entrants pour
la sncf
et alors comment est ce que l'on fait et
pourquoi pas pour les agriculteurs
pourquoi pas pour les artisans
pourquoi pas pour les salariés du privé
je veux dire une réforme pendant 40 ans
alors après j'ai cru comprendre qu'ils
rétropédale est mais pas complètement
donc je ne sais pas où on en est nous on
a le mérite
contrairement au rassemblement national
et contrairement à la république en
marche on a une position sur les
retraites qui mérite encore d'être
affinés c'est pour ça qu'on continue
avec ce groupe de travail a avancé
dessus mais voilà les principes auxquels
on est attaché dans le prolongement de
ce que dit christian il ya quand même
deux différences majeures entre notre
contre projet et ce qu'exprime emmanuel
macron 1 emmanuel macron ment aux
français pour sauver le régime des
retraites
il faut dire la vérité aux français
comme ça se passe dans tous les pays
d'europe
il faut travailler davantage nous vivons
plus longtemps donc nous nous disons
qu'il faut travailler davantage et le
flou et l'ambiguïté entretenue par le
présent à public et ses différents porte
parole qu'on conduit à cette anxiété et
donc à ces tensions
il ment nous disons les choses
deuxièmement ce qu'il annonce est fondée
sur des singes justice profonde rien sur
la pénibilité attaquer les droits
familiaux et conjugaux donc s'en prendre
à la politique familiale
pire encore aller chercher l'argent
auprès des caisses excédentaire je pense
à tous les indépendants les médecins les
avocats toutes les professions libérales
sur des gens qui cotisent plus et à qui
on va prendre l'argent pour équilibrer
le régime
lula propositions que nous faisons c'est
une proposition à la fois de vérité et
de justice sociale et donc c'est
radicalement différent ya pas de posture
c'est une différence politique majeure
entre le présent et public et nous
monsieur pressent bonjour sophy du pont
pour quotidien une question sur patrick
balkany
il a fait savoir qu'il souhaitait être
candidat à levallois perret pour les
municipales n'ont qu'à ni aux finitions
ne répondrai après bonjour je voulais
savoir si vous étiez vous parlez d'un
reporter l'âge légal de départ en
retraite
est ce que vous êtes d'accord sur sur
une sur un seuil sur une nage le point
d'équilibré qui est communément retenu
ses 64 ans mais il doit se faire
progressivement c'est à dire qu'on passe
pas du jour au lendemain donc là il faut
c'est pour ça qu'on continue à
travailler et qu'on a ce groupe de
travail pour regarder effectivement
comment la sortie des régimes spéciaux
peut s'étaler dans le temps et comment
on arrive en combien de temps on arrive
c'est au tour de 64 ans bras après ça
tout ça peut faire la discussion mais
c'est ça comme on les fait de 60 à 62
ans c'est ce que je vous dise et c'est
ça qui mérite débat et c'est les sujets
sur lesquels on est en train de
travailler avec ces entre autres un des
sujets qui va être évoquée à la fois par
par eric woerth
rené paul savary et stéphane bierry mais
l'idée c'est d'arriver là et ensuite
moi ce que je pense c'est de pouvoir
l'indexer sur l'allongement de la durée
de la vie en bonne santé ce qui nous
évite d'avoir tous les cinq ans
la nécessité d'avoir le grand soir c'est
à dire quand une fois qu'on peut se
caler là dessus ça nous permet d'avancer
sur la réforme des retraites sur des
manifestations importantes massive
demain notamment et peut-être samedi
la préfète de police tout comme
christophe castaner ce matin disent
qu'il y aura sûrement des casseurs des
black blocks des gens radicaux dans ces
manifestations
double question est-ce que selon vous la
violence est désormais inéluctable dans
les mouvements sociaux dans les
manifestations et surtout qu'est ce que
vous proposez
concrètement pour éviter qu'il y ait des
violences et des dégradations demain et
peut-être samedi d'abord que le
gouvernement sorte de cette ambiguïté
c'est à dire qu'il ya un moment on a une
feuille quand on est au gouvernement on
a fait deux ans et demi soit disant de
de concertation est incapable de poser
un texte sur la table
c'est invraisemblable et donc c'est cela
aussi qui génère cette anxiété
en revanche les violences de quelque
nature que ce soit sont en aucun cas
acceptable par qui que ce soit mais mais
je vous dit deux ans et demi de
concertation au bout de deux ans et demi
se passe quoi on fait rentrer le haut
commissaire au gouvernement
et après on explique qu'on va réouvrir
une discussion on peut pas effacer trop
vite l'échec de la méthode des manuels
macron dont a parlé christian jacob
au départ vous mesurez bien de manière
assez objective les deux mondes
totalement étranger qui lie à entre la
promesse initiale à l'élection des
manuels macron qui est celle de
rassembler et la droite et la gauche et
donc l'ensemble de nos concitoyens et
l'état aujourd'hui de saccage de
l'opinion dans dans notre pays et
d'ailleurs il ya des études d'opinion
qui sont assez intéressantes
une majorité de nos concitoyens sont
favorables à une réforme des retraites
ce qui veut dire que contrairement à une
idée reçue nos concitoyens sont
parfaitement capables d'accepter des
réformes qu'ils avaient plus de mal à
accepter par le passé en revanche ils ne
font pas confiance au gouvernement
pourquoi parce que dans l'adn de la
méthode des manuels macron il y à
l'injustice sociale
désormais l'ensemble des actes qu'ils
posent emmanuel macron durant le début
de son quinquennat a permis aux français
de comprendre que l'idée qu'il se
faisait de la société
une idée injustes ces différentes
occurrences sur les premiers de cordée
sur ceux qui ont réussi et ceux qui ne
sont rien et nous sommes là en rendez
vous celui des retraites qui est
singulier parce que c'est le résumé
d'une vie et donc naturellement ça
cristallise plus cette attention aux
questions sociales et la vérité c'est
que emmanuel macron et son gouvernement
ont une vision injuste de la société
lorsque vous l'appliquez un sujet aussi
sensible que les retraites alors vous
avez le résultat que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
et pardon de vous dire aussi que sur la
question de la posture possible je pense
que c'est un rendez-vous de
responsabilité pour la droite
républicaine et que la manière dont
notre famille politique depuis plusieurs
semaines a abordé le sujet montre le
devoir de responsabilité que nous avons
nous ne sommes pas dans une opposition
systématique au moment nous vous disons
que nous sommes défavorables à l'idée
qui semble émerger de cette réforme nous
vous disons aussi quelles sont nos
propositions précises sur la question du
régime que nous préférons sur la
question de des 64 ans et nous allons
aller plus loin dans les semaines qui
viennent sur la question qui évoquait
christian jacob notamment de la
pénibilité et des petites pensions qui
sont deux sujets pour nous absolument
fondamentaux on marque une première
étape en n'étant pas dans une opposition
bête et méchante
c'est une vraie prise de conscience que
nous avons et dans les semaines qui
viennent nous irons plus loin mais il ya
l'échec de la méthode
il ya sûrement un chemin de
reconstruction pour la droite
républicaine avec un rendez vous
particulier qui est celui des retraites
sur lequel nous avons une légitimité
toute particulière au regard de ce qui a
été fait par par le passé ça fait quand
même quelques temps que nous n'avions
pas tous été uniforme sur une ligne
politique et sur un sujet aussi
important
ça veut dire quelque chose
à peu près tout il faudrait demander à
stephen à stéphane bierry aussi bien
côté patronat que salarié je pense que
toutes les organisations étaient vus moi
j'ai assisté à pas mal de
deux rendez vous je n'ai pas tous faits
on a vu
la cfdt et fo
toutes les organisations toutes les
organisations patronales fâcheuse et
puis tout en tête mais sans pourra vous
les donner parce qu'on a la liste de
toutes les organisations côté rocio oui
je vais savoir vous dites que vous avez
une position uniforme
est ce que guillaume pelletier maintient
sa proposition qui le développe dans son
livre d'un système par points justement
qui permet de ne pas se poser la
question sempiternel de l'âge de départ
à la retraite que vous collectivement
mettez autour de 64 ans pour arriver à
une position unanime et c'est notre
volonté est à chacun et communes
il faut que chacun à la fois défendre
ses convictions et puis parfois renonce
à ses propres raisonnement la position
que vient de présenter christian jacob
complété par aurélien partagé dans
toutes nos réunions de travail depuis
maintenant un mois et demi sanctuary zay
par une réunion la semaine dernière mer
mardi avec le comité stratégique et
toutes les personnalités notre mouvement
est celle ci c'est à dire une réforme de
vérité fondée sur l'allongement de la
durée du travail
faut dire la vérité aux français pour
garantir le pouvoir d'achat des
retraites pour garantir l'équilibré du
système
il nous faut aller vers cette réforme
nous sommes par ailleurs très attaché à
l'idée de la répartition et la
solidarité dans le prolongement des
fruits du conseil national de la
résistance se veut pas dire que chacun
eric woerth moi et tant d'autres on peut
pas faire des propositions
complémentaires mais le tronc commun qui
a été présenté à cet instant c'est le
tronc commun de toute notre famille et
aurélien a raison de souligner c'est la
première fois depuis longtemps
outre les questions dites régaliennes
que je les grandes questions économiques
et sociales
nous sommes d'accord une réforme de
vérité et une réforme de justice sociale
c'est notre grande différence avec
emmanuel macron mêmes mâcon c'est le
président des injustices il exaspère
tous les français et ses injustices
conduisent à des tensions dans la
société française et ce matin il y a
l'opposition républicaine qui fait une
proposition très concrète et qu'ils
appellent le gouvernement à entendre des
propositions pour sauver notre régime
des retraites et garantir la cohésion
nationale
et écoutez écoutez il ya un temps il ya
un temps pour chaque pour chaque chose
c'est un sujet l'investissement les
investitures à levallois nous verrons ça
avec la fédération des hauts-de-seine
avec patrick balkany moi j'ai toujours
témoigner mon affection
patrick mais voilà oui mais on en est on
n'en est pas là à ce stade on vous
tiendra informés quand on en sera là je
me permets de sur notre question sur les
retraites il ya un de vos amis députés
et collègues qui s'appelle monsieur
taugourdeau il a posé une question au
gouvernement et dans sa question
il a parlé et il a semblé nier le
réchauffement climatique en disant
c'était un prétendu réchauffement
climatique
est ce qu'à titre personnel vous avez
été choqué vous trois par cette
expression est ce que vous souhaitez qui
s'excuse publiquement
non non la réponse est claire en
revanche bon le réchauffement climatique
c'est une réalité qui n'est pas qui
n'est pas contestable et donc nous avons
d'ailleurs là aussi un travail de fond
qui est qui est important pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique que
ce soit à la fois sur le sujet de
l'énergie sur celui de l'isolation sur
celui des énergies renouvelables etc
donc on travaille on travaille dessus
on a eu d'ailleurs une commission
denquête bon moi je vous invite à
regarder de près qui était faite par
julien ouvert où il ya un très bon
travail de fond sur notamment sous
l'angle de l'énergie dont quoi le
réchauffement climatique qui n'est pas
contestable